[Musik]
Deutschland liegt flach schon 10
Millionen Deutsche sind krank
Medikamente sind knapp Kinderstationen
überfüllt was hat die maskenpflicht mit
dieser Krankheitswelle zu tun konnte
unser Immunsystem nicht trainieren das
ist ein Thema bei uns heute und ich
begrüße spannende Gäste ob man oder frau
immer mehr Menschen zweifeln an ihrem
biologischen Geschlecht das sagt
Publizistin Bettina Röhl sie hält das
mit Blick auf das geplante
selbstbestimmungsgesetz für ein
gefährlichen Trend der Einsatz von
hormonblockern schon bei Kindern sein
Verbrechen
Innenminister sieht die Demokratie in
Gefahr hat damit auch die großrazieher
gegen Reichsbürger begründet unsere
Dienste funktionieren das sagt
experience Chef Gerhard Schindler der
Winter ist brutal die Energieexperten
schlagen Alarm die Gasspeicher Lehren
sich Journalisten Daniel Gräber waren
seit Monaten vor Energie Engpässen und
fordert jetzt die Regierung zu
entschlossenem Handeln auf seine Partei
reagiert mit die FDP der
Bundestagsabgeordnete Martin Gassner
Herz besorgt sich um immer mehr
abgehängte Kinder denen es einfach an
allem fehlt an Bildung und damit eben
auch an Aufstiegschancen ja die Kinder
sie sind vor allem jetzt die
notleidenden ich habe es eingangs
bereits gesagt fast 10 Millionen
Deutsche liegen derzeit flach Grippe
Erkältung dass er ess-virus die
Kinderkliniken laufen voll Kleinkinder
wenn abgewiesen viele Apotheken haben
nicht mehr mehr Fiebersaft die Berliner
Charité hat alle verschiebbaren
Operationen jetzt des Jahresende
abgesagt und viele fragen sich hat uns
der maskenzwang diese Krankheitswelle
beschert ja das sagt Jakob Maske
Sprecher des Berufsverbands der Kinder
und jugendärzte besonders die kleinsten
hätten nicht die Möglichkeit gehabt ihr
Immunsystem zu trainieren
exfamilienministerin Christina Schröder
betont das Schulkinder weit mehrmals
getragen mussten als die meisten
Erwachsenen sie sagt jetzt sollte sich
herausstellen dass wir ihn
gesundheitlich geschadet haben dann muss
ich der Staat bei unseren Kindern
entschuldigen
was haben wir unseren Kindern da angetan
also ich bin jetzt in den corona-thema
muss ich gegangen nicht so drin und habe
auch diese ganze Schulgeschichte ich
habe das immer nur von außen verfolgt
und kann mich da eigentlich nicht so
engagieren wenn das wirklich so ist das
natürlich in den Medien gelesen dann
finde ich muss man den tatsächlich
nachgehen weil man hat ja immer die
Kinder als Unbekannte gehabt die sollten
zwar alles machen was getragen zu Hause
bleiben aber wir wussten nicht erkranken
sie auch und wenn sie jetzt über eine
Hintertür sie galt mal als supersprecher
sogar deswegen
ist das finde ich also auf jeden Fall
aufgeklärt werden würde ich sagen
in der Apotheke da gibt's nicht mehr
mehr fiebersäfte Kinder werden teilweise
40 Kilometer weit weggefahren weil sie
im Krankenhaus nicht behandelt werden
weil die Intensivstation in der
volllaufen ist das auch ein Versagen ein
krankes Gesundheitssystem
ich glaube im deutschen
Gesundheitssystem ist sehr vieles
ungesund und es ist wahrscheinlich krank
und ich finde es ganz bemerkenswert wie
viel Geld eigentlich doch in diesem
System steckt welche welche Milliarden
Summen da eigentlich umgesetzt werden
nur offensichtlich landen sie ja nicht
dort wo sie wo sie gebraucht werden und
ich glaube dass Deutsch
Gesundheitssystem leidet an einer
gefährlichen Mischung aus einer Art
versuchten Marktwirtschaft dass man
versucht manches durch mehr
Privatisierung durch mehr Wettbewerb
kosteneffizient zu lösen auf der anderen
Seite aber doch eine staatliche
Steuerung hat durch eine Bürokratie bei
der vielfältigste Adresse
Interessenverbände auch eine Rolle
spielen wo glaube ich einfach einiges
grundsätzlich im Magen liegt und es
zeigt sich jetzt am Beispiel der
Kinderkrankenhäuser aber ich glaube das
äh das ist auch nur die Spitze eines
Eisbergs es ist auch eine total
dramatische
sitzen auch im Familienausschuss ich
habe gerade gesagt Christina Schröder
sagt wenn das so ist dass wir auch durch
die Masken und die ganzen Maßnahmen
unsere Kinder jetzt in diese Situation
gebracht haben dann muss ich der Staat
entschuldigen sehen Sie das auch so ich
kann das medizinisch nicht beurteilen ob
das einen Masken liegt wir machen uns im
Familienausschuss vor allem Gedanken
darum was muss man jetzt tun da sind
einmal die Gesundheitsexperten gefragt
was im klinischen Bereich gemacht werden
kann dass Kinder auch gut versorgt
werden in unseren Krankenhäusern und wir
in der Familienpolitik machen uns
Gedanken was wir tun können dass die
Kinder die durch die lockdowns in den
Schulen viele Chancen verpasst haben
viele
bildungs-teile bekommen haben dass das
möglichst schnell wieder aufgeholt
werden kann dazu werde ich ja nachher
auch mein Thema haben da bin ich fitter
als ein Thema zu beurteilen was das für
medizinische Auswirkungen hat ja schon
längst beurteilt das wird von Virologen
oder das wird von Ärzten beurteilt und
es gibt viele Experten die sagen das
Immunsystem der Kinder konnte nicht
trainiert werden dadurch haben sich
Infekte die sich sonst jeden Winter
holen eben aufgestaut und deswegen
kommen sie jetzt geballt auf die Kinder
zu es scheint also diesen Zusammenhang
zu geben und man muss ja auch sagen das
ist eine Tatsache die Kinder haben viel
mehr Maske tragen müssen als die
Erwachsenen die Schulen man konnte nur
mit Maske reingehen das galt in der
Firma am Arbeitsplatz dann oft nicht
mehr also die Kinder haben besonders
gelitten in dieser Pandemie waren wir ja
dann für Sie der Punkt gekommen dass Sie
dem zustimmen würden was Christina
Schröder sagt wann wäre der Punkt
gekommen dass sie sagen ja stimmt da
brauchen wir eine Entschuldigung ich bin
mir sicher wir müssen es aufarbeiten
danach wissenschaftlich woran hat es
gelegen damit wir in Zukunft keine
Fehler machen jetzt ist wichtig dass wir
uns darum kümmern dass die Kinder akut
medizinisch gut versorgt werden in den
äh die Lage in den Kinderkrankenhäusern
im Griff ist und Eltern ich bin frisch
Papa geworden sich keine Sorgen machen
müssen oder keine zu großen Sorgen
machen müssen was ist wenn mein Kind
krank ist und sich sicher sein können
dass es gut versorgt wird das wünschen
sich mit Sicherheit alle
meine Eltern alle Menschen auch sonst
Herr Schiller was ist ihr Eindruck es
war so dass die kleinsten ja vor allem
auch in die Verantwortung gezogen wurden
um die Älteren zu schützen jetzt kann
man den Eindruck gewinnen jetzt wenn sie
im Stich gelassen also ich würde jetzt
gerne einfach mal so ein Stück auf die
Metaebene gehen und fragen was ist das
schief gelaufen und da frage ich mich
wie wird Politik heute noch gemacht
machens die Politiker machen es
sogenannte Sachverständige und Experten
und wir haben ja alle noch die vielen
Talkshows in Erinnerung zum Thema Virus
Schule Beruf und so weiter und ich
glaube das ist ein bisschen
durcheinander geraten also dieser misch
Macht zwischen einerseits
Expertenmeinung dann findet man das aber
nicht gut dann nimmt man einen anderen
Experten und am Schluss kommt irgendeine
Entscheidung raus und die Ergebnisse
sehen wir jetzt gerade das ist ja nicht
die einzige falsche Entscheidung die die
getroffen worden ist nicht glaube
ich würde jetzt lieber das Ergebnis
sagen ich glaube man muss hingehen und
muss noch mal fragen wie soll zukünftig
Politikberatung stattfinden damit wir
bessere und validere Entscheidung
treffen können denn sowas darf nicht
noch mal passieren es würde mich
trotzdem interessieren welche Punkte
wollten sie dann noch oder welche sind
da noch in ihrem Kopf wenn sie sagen es
wurden viele falsche Entscheidungen
getroffen also ich beispielsweise bin
voll darauf reingefallen auf die
Impfpflicht ich dachte das ist eine gute
Idee weil wenn etwas hilft dann impfen
aber inzwischen stellt sich heraus dass
impfen hilft einem selbst aber es hilft
nicht dagegen dass man den Virus
weiterträgt so und ich finde das ist ein
ein weiteres Beispiel dafür wie hilflos
wir uns in diese Krise begeben haben und
deshalb glaube ich brauchen wir eine
neue Art von Politikberatung was
wünschen sie sich da genau das ist
entspannendes Thema wir wollen ja alle
ich glaube das ein uns wahrscheinlich
hier in einem Tisch sitzen das so etwas
nicht mehr passiert für die Kinder kommt
zu spät so wird
könnte sagen weil für die kommt zu spät
die Kinderstationen laufen voll und die
Kinder so bin ich mir sicher haben am
meisten gelitten in dieser Krise was
glauben Sie was müsste passieren dass
solche Fehler nicht noch mal passieren
eine andere Beratung ja ich glaube wir
brauchen Experten die dann da sind wenn
sie benötigt werden hier hat man ja bei
der viruskrise festgestellt man man
nimmt sich den der in der Uni am
nächsten ist hier in der Hauptstadt hat
man einen Professor gefunden dann ein
Professor in Bonn und und und ich glaube
das das hat gezeigt wie wenig
vorbereiten wir auf so etwas wie eine
Pandemie waren und deshalb wäre es ganz
wichtig dass ein Gesundheitsministerium
aber auch ein Familienministerium ein
Verkehrsministerium feste
Expertengruppen schafft die sich mit der
Zukunft befassen und nicht mit der
Aufarbeitung der Vergangenheit und das
ist glaube ich ein Appell der
berücksichtigt werden können Sie dieses
Appell hat die Bundesregierung sich
teilweise auch Experten gesucht und
andere Meinungen von anderen Experten
einfach nicht hören wollen also ich
finde den Aufruf der da dahinter steckt
sehr gut weil sie ja sagen wir sollen
kommen zu einer
produktiven politischen
Auseinandersetzung wo man sich um die
besten Lösungen streitet und gemeinsam
die besten Lösungen sucht sich gut
beraten lässt von Experten und überlegt
gute Entscheidungen trifft ich glaube
das tut auch unsere
Demokratieentwicklung sehr gut wenn wir
uns darauf verständigen dass ja dass wir
so ein bisschen Alarmismus rausnehmen
und uns vielleicht auch mal selbst in
der Krise Zeit nehmen gut über Lösungen
nachzudenken ich glaube wir hatten in
der Pandemie sogar Glück also die was
die expertenlage angeht also die
Möglichkeiten bestätigen wird ich glaube
viele fühlen sich dort in ihrer Meinung
dann eher an den Rand gedrängt gerade am
Anfang der Pandemie war ja schon eine
große Expertise im RKI da und
große weltweit anerkannte
Wissenschaftler waren zufällig deutsche
und ich glaube dass da schon am Anfang
der Erkenntnis Erkenntnisgewinns viel
Sachverstand da war wie man dann danach
damit umgegangen ist und ob man ihn
wirklich immer gut nur produktiven
politikfindung eingesetzt hat ist eine
andere Frage aber ich glaube wir haben
schon auch gute Experten und
Wissenschaftler weiterhin darf ich da
direkt was dazu sagen wir sprechen jetzt
wahrscheinlich von von Herrn Professor
Christian Thorsten der der wirklich eine
Kapazität auf dem Gebiet der
coronavirenforschung ist aber das große
Problem ist es ein Mann aus dem Labor
der weiß wie man ein Virus zerlegt und
eventuell sogar auch wenn man einen
einen bastelt das ist ja auch so ein
Problem dass dieses Virus ich würde
sagen sogar mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
aus dem Chinesischen Labor stammte und
das auch Leute während Drosten am Anfang
der Pandemie vertuschen oder zumindest
kleinreden wollten diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit Herr Drosten ist aber
überhaupt kein Experte davon wie man
eine solche in der Gesellschaft oder so
eine Erkrankung die sich die sich als
Pandemie der entpuppt wie man die in der
Gesellschaft als Gesamt Gebilde sinnvoll
eindämmt davon hat er einfach würde ich
fast sagen fast zu wenig Ahnung wie ich
aber er wurde zum Erklären für allem wie
man das Coronavirus bekämpft und Leute
die das ein bisschen ähm die für
vernünftigere ganzheitlichere Maßnahmen
liegt plädiert haben und zum Beispiel
nach Schweden verwiesen haben die wurden
jetzt zu Beginn der Pandemie die wurden
ja fast so als würden Sie jetzt unsere
alten als würden sie einen ein
Massenmord in unseren Altenheim
veranstalten Deutschland
zum Beispiel zum Beispiel den den
Professor Streck zum Beispiel auch im
Virologe aber jemand der der nicht nur
im Labor forscht sondern der erste
rausgegangenes Feld der hat ja beide das
war ja genau das was sind wir wohl der
wurde ja dann wirklich diffamiert aufs
Übelste und zwar auch von Herrn Thorsten
dass er Drosten scheint für mich auch
eine sehr alte Person zu sein der ist
sehr genossen hat dass er dann auf
einmal der Erlöser ist und ähm das das
das das war ungesund das gab keine
offene Debatte weder in der Politik noch
unter Experten in Deutschland und ich
würde nicht sagen dass wir jetzt nur
noch vorne gucken müssen wir müssen
natürlich auch dieses
teilweise versagen und die Fehler die
gemacht wurden da da anfangen und da
gibt's noch einiges aufzuarbeiten es
gibt auch einen großen Teil der
Bevölkerung in Deutschland und zwar sind
das auch diejenigen die vielleicht eher
skeptisch waren sich nicht sofort impfen
lassen haben wollen die haben auch eine
wirkliche Wut im Bauch und eine
Unzufriedenheit mit mit unserem
politischen System und den zuliebe und
damit auch dieser ganzen Gesellschaft
für die bemusters auf den Tischen
aufgeklärt werden und dann kann man nach
vorne schauen aber jetzt zu sagen wir
haben jetzt anderes zu tun und so mal
weiter also dass das damit kommt man
glaube ich nicht durch das habe ich auch
so nicht gemeint sondern ich glaube das
habe ich so auch nicht gemeint ich habe
gemeint wir müssen schauen dass wir was
produktives draus lernen und eben auch
keine offene Debatte
das also ich glaube auch dass die
Debatte die wir geführt haben rund um
Corona nicht immer produktiver
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
gehöre zu den sehr nachsichtigen Leuten
die eigentlich fanden dass am Anfang die
Regierung finde ich viele Fehler gemacht
haben zum Beispiel das am Anfang keine
Masken da waren aber ich habe eigentlich
den großen Vorsprung gegeben es war eine
ganz neue Krankheit es war am Anfang
eine Gefahr aus China Italien in New
York wo wo wo man einfach nicht wusste
ob es noch noch gefährlicher ist als
gefährlich wo man sich dann hat auch in
viele Sachen glaube ich reinreißen
lassen das ist dann auch sind dann auch
die Medien ja die Bilder aus Peking wo
alles abgeschottet oder aus Wuhan dass
das hat man sich dann vielleicht zum
Vorwurf gemacht zum Vorbild genommen
also ich bin da etwas nachsichtiger ähm
und habe gedacht eigentlich hatte die
Bundesregierung glaube ich nicht dass
ein schlechte im Sinn zumindest am
Anfang und ich fand auch die Impfpflicht
eigentlich wenn ich ihn Pflicht aber die
Impfungen in der tolle machen nach einem
Jahr dass sie da war und da sind aber
eben nicht alle in der Gesellschaft
mitgegangen und dann hat es natürlich
offenbar Gräben gegeben wo einige
ausgegrenzt wurden und so weiter dass
das aber vom ganz vom Grunde her war ich
da eher so dass ich gedacht habe es wäre
also ich bin da einfach nicht so
kritisch
gelandet und ich gebe auch zurück bin
ich in die Niederung was alles schief
gelaufen ist dann eingedrungen sondern
ich ich war dann mir so ein Corona
scharf
gebe ich zu ähm ja also ich bin auch
geimpft und mir hat auch keine
Nebenwirkung ich ich hatte Corona bis
heute nicht
Ewigkeiten zu Hause verbracht Aufträge
Vorträge alles weggefahren also ich
glaube schon zu den Betroffenen als
freie Autorin aber ähm ich habe ganz
viele Freunde die mir also ganz die
schlimmsten Videos geschickt haben und
ich ich weiß wirklich auch bis heute
nicht vielleicht haben die Recht
vielleicht Wahnsinn viele Sachen falsch
gelaufen also ich ich möchte es wirklich
am Ende nicht verurteilen
Abstand dazu zu kriegen und auch bei
gewissen Diskussionen einfach nicht
teilzunehmen oder die auszuwenden aber
jetzt sind wir drei Jahre später wir
haben nur immer mehr dass viele Corona
die angeblichen corona-leugner und die
ganz große Gegenwart der höre ich jetzt
in vielen Medien wenn ich das so lese
dass in vielen Sachen doch vielleicht
recht hatten mit einigen die Kritiker
also die Leute
Regierungs treu und ähm
habe ich auch viele anfallenden gekriegt
wieder rum von der Szene nämlich aber
ich denke mal dass das ist richtig eine
Nacharbeitung sollte so sein dass also
wo die Kritiker Recht hatten finde ich
sollte das auch im Nachhinein anerkannt
werden und ich umgekehrt würde ich mir
wünschen dass die Gesellschaft wieder
etwas mehr an der Stelle zusammen weg es
ist eigentlich kein kann aber durchaus
arbeiten das Besondere Leute die
diskriminiert wurden
und so weiter ich hoffe dass die
Gesellschaft da sind wie ich finde es
zusammen ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema
das Blick auf die lange Bank geschoben
werden darf darüber ähnlich wie ein
Thema über das wir jetzt auch sprechen
wollen auf die lange Bank geschoben
wurde nämlich die Stromversorgung in
Deutschland eine Kriegsausbruch wurde
relativ schnell klar Deutschlands wirken
Energieproblem bekommen dennoch die
Atome Ausstieg der ist beschlossene
Sache die drei LKWs die sind im
streckenbetrieb und sie sagen wenn wir
so weitermachen dann wird's Wetter kalt
und auch dunkel vielleicht dann schon zu
Weihnachten Ihre Kamera
ja wir erleben gerade im Zeitraffer
ausgelöst durch den Ukraine Krieg und
die ausbleibenden Gaslieferung nach
Deutschland erleben wir im Zeitraffer
etwas was
Leute zu denen ich auch erzähle schon
lange bevor Putin in die Ukraine
einmarschiert ist befürchtet haben
nämlich dass diese schöne Erzählungen
der Energiewende die wir in Deutschland
schon seit einigen Jahren inzwischen von
fast allen Parteien ursprünglich mal für
den Grünen aber inzwischen von fast
allen Parteien mit erzählt dass diese
Erzählung grandios scheitert und sie
sich eigentlich als ein Märchen entpuppt
eine schöne märchenerzählung die einfach
an der Wirklichkeit zerbricht und zwar
erleben wir diesen Winter das nicht nur
das Gas knapp zu werden tot so wie es
aussieht kommen wir je nach Temperaturen
durch diesen Winter doch noch
einigermaßen durch was die Heizung
betrifft der nächste Winter steht aber
vor der Tür und gleichzeitig erleben wir
gerade das ist mit der Stromversorgung
wirklich eng wird und wir vielleicht im
Januar oder Februar durchaus mit
Stromausfällen rechnen müssen die dann
zwar angekündigt werden also keine
Blackouts im eigentlichen Sinne aber die
glaube ich viele Bürger zum Aufwecken
aus diesem Märchen bringen und ich
erinnere da an das Kaisers neue Kleider
man sagt denn letztendlich der Kaiser
ist hier nackt so stehen wir jetzt also
da quasi nackt nicht vorbereitet wie
sollen wir durch diesen Winter kommen
was glauben Sie was kann im schlimmsten
Fall sie haben gesagt Stromausfälle
befürchten sie schon im Januar Februar
was kann im schlimmsten Fall passieren
dass Sie uns einmal Eintauchen in dieses
Szenario ähm ja es wird jetzt immer vom
vom Blackout geredet und dann sagen die
die Netzbetreiber und und auch die in
der Regierung Verantwortlichen sofort
nein nein das Blackout Risiko ist gering
das vermeide ich nichts beurteilen ein
bundesweite
die Lichter ausgehen weil der Strom
fällt nennen wir das Blackout so ist es
im Alltagssprachgebrauch gemeint die
Fachleute netzingenieure die Reden von
Blackout nur wenn es ein
unkontrollierter gesamtzusammenbruch des
gesamten Stromnetzes ist der dann
durchaus auch Tage andauern kann weil
das befürchten sie aber nicht das kann
jederzeit und zwar immer passieren die
Gefahr ist immer da aber sie hängt jetzt
nicht an der Strom mangelage unbedingt
so das die Gefahr ist aber auch da die
muss man sie auch vorbereiten was aber
durchaus ich für wahrscheinlich halte
und was auch sich besonders in
Baden-Württemberg schon erste
Ankündigung in die Richtung gab ist das
die Stromnetzbetreiber um einen Blackout
zu verhindern sich nicht mehr anders zu
helfen zu wissen als den sogenannten
braun-out das sind kontrollierte
Stromausfälle zeitlich begrenzt für 90
Minuten vielleicht in einzelne
Stadtteilen Gebieten je nachdem machen
wo einfach mal der Strom abgestellt wird
weil einfach in dem Moment nicht genug
Strom da ist und das ist wenn man
vorgewandt wird zu verkaufen und der
Tiefkühltruhe bleibt vielleicht für 19
Minuten auch noch einigermaßen
Privathaushalte aber was bedeutet für
die Wirtschaft die Frage stellt sich und
ich glaube politisch wird es auch
verheerend weil es wird dann einige
Leute geben die dann sagen liebe
Bundesregierung was treibt die da
eigentlich wie kann das sein direkt
weiter Liebe Bundesregierung was treibt
wieder eigentlich wir haben sie ja hier
sitzen Herz von der FDP mit in der
Regierung ich bemerke dass wir in jeder
Sitzungswoche uns mit dem Thema Energie
befassen und in der dynamischen Lage da
auch immer wieder neue Entscheidungen
treffen damit genau das was sie
befürchten nicht eintreten wird wichtig
ist glaube ich dass wir schnell
reagieren gute
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen treffen beim Gas
haben wir jetzt mit den lg-terminist
wirklich Gas gegeben im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes
ein Prozent jetzt bei dieser Kälte ne es
ist besonders kalt ist es besonders hart
also die Speicher sind ja weiterhin noch
noch ganz gut gefüllt jetzt kommen die
lng-termin ist nach und nach ans Netz
das erste jetzt am Samstag und dann bin
ich zuversichtlich dass wir die
zahlreicher beim Gas im nächsten Jahr
auch voll bekommen mit mit LNG Gas und
ja beim bei der Stromversorgung treffen
wir jede Woche Entscheidungen wie wir
jedes Kilowatt das zur Verfügung steht
bisher nutzen können und ich glaube das
ist auch richtig so wir sind eine
dynamische Lage man müsste also bei
Ihnen bei der FDP da meldet sich jetzt
kein Unternehmen durch die BASF zum
Beispiel die Alarm schlägt und sagt also
wenn es so weitergeht wissen wir nicht
mehr wie wir produzieren sollen doch
selbstverständlich melden Sie sich bei
uns und fragen nach aber sie ich glaube
es ist gut wenn wir dann nicht mit Panik
reagieren und kopflos sagen ja es wird
alles furchtbar sondern wenn wir das als
Auftrag für uns nehmen uns sehr an
Schreibtisch zu setzen und Lösungen zu
finden gerade Strom zur Mangelware wir
sind Industrienation ich glaube jetzt
mit Schreibtisch und Lösungen ich glaube
wir haben diesen Punkt ein bisschen
überschritten kann das sein
ich glaube wie gesagt wir haben ja auch
schon viele Entscheidungen getroffen die
uns da weiterhelfen werden
aber wir haben die Entscheidung
getroffen dass die AKWs über den über
den Dezember hinaus bleiben das ist wenn
ich da kurz einhaken darf das finde ich
also es ist ja ihrer Partei und Fraktion
hoch anzurechnen dass sie es geschafft
haben das durchzusetzen dass wenigstens
die drei die jetzt noch laufen
Atomkraftwerke zumindest mal bis April
laufen die große Frage ist nur was kommt
danach ich spreche auch mit FDP
Abgeordneten die in dem Thema drin sind
und habe dass die auch direkt gefragt
und im Hintergrund ich habe dann immer
gefragt ja gebt ihr euch da mich jetzt
zufrieden oder wartet erstmal ab und
dann haben die immer gesagt ja mal
abwarten wie der Winter ist danach ist
eine andere Lage sprich wir machen eine
Energiepolitik wo Entscheidungen
getroffen werden die Jahrzehnte Bestand
haben und die für Jahrzehnte im Voraus
auch getroffen werden müssen betreiben
wird von Winter zu Winter wird der
Winter kalt was jetzt kommt der
Stromverbrauch in Frankreich wieder
dadurch vor allem steigen und mit Strom
Heiz und das wird auch bei uns zu
Problemen führen dann gibt es vielleicht
dann spätestens im April wieder eine
neue ermüdende atomkraft-diskussion wo
man dann wieder auf grüne Befindlichkeit
Rücksicht nehmen musste dann vielleicht
einen streckbetrieb für einen
streckstreckstreckbetrieb bis zum
nächsten Winter beschließt aber das ist
doch kein Konzept man muss doch diese
ganze Energiewende mal grundsätzlich auf
den Prüfstand stellen und pragmatisch
entscheiden wo machen erneuerbare Sinn
wo brauchen wir vielleicht doch noch
mehr und länger unsere Atomkraftwerke
die zu den sichersten der Welt gehören
wo können wir Gas im eigenen Land
fordern fördern das muss doch einen
Gesamtstrategie sein und nicht von
Landtagswahl zu Landtagswahl und von
Winter zu Winter mit der
Energiesicherheit unseres Landes zu
spielen das ist doch also ich merke ich
bin da fassungslos und gerade ihre
Partei wurde dafür gewählt dass sie
diesen Unsinn aufhält oder zumindest
verhindert und das viele FDP Wähler ist
für diese Frage glaube ich wird
entscheidend sein ob sie muss man noch
mehr Kreuz bei Ihnen machen das sollten
sich bewusst sein
wenn sie reagieren oder das einfach mal
so hinnehmen ich also sie wissen ja dass
ist nicht an uns gescheitert ist noch
eine noch eine längere Laufzeit für die
Atomkraftwerke zu erreichen und jetzt
sind wir gespannt dass der Wirtschafts-
und Energieminister dieses Strategie
vorliegt die Sie diese verlangen und der
ist da im Lied und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir dann eine gute
Lösung finden also ich glaube nicht
daran dass die Atomkraftwerke wieder
aufgenommen werden also habe ich habe
jetzt verstanden das ist jetzt dann auch
das Ende und ich würde dann positiv
sagen wie Atomkraft ist tot es lebe die
Kernkraft es müssen glaube ich neue
Lösungen in Richtung Kernkraft weil sie
gefragt hatten das ist eigentlich mein
Stand äh hier es wird glaube ich nie mit
den allein mit den erneuerbaren Energien
gehen das ist ja dieses Märchen den wir
jetzt seit 30 Jahren hinterherlaufen
aber das gibt ihm dieses Szenario in der
Nacht bei Flaute und so weiter da gibt
es keinen und deshalb bin ich aber
positiv und zuversichtlich dass die
Vernunft in der Regierung siegen wird
die neue Kernkraft es gibt ja jetzt
Ansätze das habe ich gelesen in China
aber auch in Deutschland gibt es
überall wahrscheinlich noch ja aber das
geht auch relativ schnell also wenn die
Medien liest also ich weiß bin jetzt
keine Kernkräfte Forschung aber ich
denke mal das was ja vor allen Dingen
versäumt wurde in den letzten 30 Jahren
ist ja eine Kernkraft zu forschen es
gibt aber die Forschung und ähm ich
denke mal dass wir in langfristig
perspektivisch die Kernkraft wieder in
Angriff nehmen werden ist ja auch das
CO2 einsparendste Energie allerdings
System allerdings bis dahin müssen wir
uns noch irgendwie so lang humpeln also
sie wollen jetzt komplett aus und dann
haben die Grünen werden niemals das ist
eine Illusion also dass die jetzt die
alten schloren die ja immer noch die
dass sie die wieder
trauen aber ich da hat es auch geschafft
den Krieg zu nutzen um Ihnen den
Pazifismus auszutreiben warum sollte ich
fragen es ist so man sollte
sich laut versuchen da auch die an die
Technik zusammen und eher neuen Lösungen
und dann von mir aus zu sagen wenn die
Leute also die neue Kernkraft überhaupt
ins Visier zu nehmen langfristiger das
ist
Entwicklungen ich glaube für den Winter
wir haben ja die Atomkraftwerke auch
noch alle drei ja noch im schnell was
mich interessieren würde wir sprechen
gleich darüber dass unsere Demokratie
gesichert ist das ist gleich ihr großes
Thema ich möchte aber einmal über die
Dienste sprechen viele befürchten sollte
es zu stromausfallen können sollte es zu
einem Blackout kommen dann könnte es
sogar so weit kommen dass es plunderung
gibt das sind sozialen Unfrieden gibt
glauben Sie darauf sind wir vorbereitet
hier ein also
meine These ist immer die die beste
Sicherheitspolitik ist eine gute
Sozialpolitik und wenn sie schwierige
soziale Verhältnisse haben haben sie
auch zwangsläufig mehr Kriminalität
insofern ist das Szenario dass sie jetzt
gerade beschreiben ein durchaus
realistisches Szenario aber ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden die deutsche Polizei
die deutschen Nachrichtendienste jetzt
schon in den Startlöchern stehen und
sich darauf vorbereiten denn dort findet
Vorbereitung statt das kann ich
versichern und insofern glaube ich nicht
dass das eine ernsthafte Gefährdung
unseres Systems sein wird wenn wir so
ein Blackout haben will also das
staatlichen Systems eine ernsthafte
Gefährdungen viele Sprachen auch darüber
inwiefern die große Razzia 3000 Beamte
waren der notwendig um die
reichsbürgerszene aufzuspringen eine
Festnahme gab es der Bundestag sollte
überfallen werden ein Staat Putsch war
geplant wir sind schon mittendrin in
ihrem Thema deswegen haben sie gleich
Ihre Kamera aber ich möchte auch an Sie
die Frage stellen glauben Sie dass das
notwendig war in dieser Größe
ich glaube dass das notwendig war das
zeigt ja
das zeigen ja erstmal die auch die
Ergebnisse und ich finde
es ist leicht gesagt Mensch das sind ja
wirre das sind ja Spinner war das
überhaupt notwendig wenn wenn wir
Sicherheit ernst nehmen wollen wenn wir
also Gefährdungen die gefährlich sind
weil sie mit Waffen Gewalt etwas
verändern wollen wenn sie Gefährdung
nehmen die Systeme verändern wollen wenn
wir wenn wir das ernst nehmen dann muss
der Staat auch mit aller härter
reagieren und darf das nicht mit einer
gewissen Laxheit machen nach dem Motto
naja das sind ja doch irgendwie ganz
komische Leute und daher finde ich hat
man hier richtig gehandelt und es ist
auch nicht so dass die
Sicherheitsbehörden diese teilweise
abstrusen Ideen dann immer als
Begründung gebracht haben denn die
Begründung ist ja für diese ganzen
Aktionen die Bildung und Unterstützung
einer terroristischen Vereinigung und
nicht ein Umsturzversuch so und das war
mit Sicherheit gegeben und insofern
halte ich das für sehr gerechtfertigt
dass dort so eingeschritten worden ist
sie gehen sogar noch einen Schritt
weiter es gab Kritik oder auch Zweifel
an dieser Maßnahme war das wirklich
notwendig in der Größe Herr Schindler
hat gerade gesagt ja und wir haben sogar
den Beweis dafür denn es gab Festnahmen
wir sehen daran dass die Gefahr richtig
eingeschätzt wurde teilen Sie diese
Auffassung
da habe ich mich zu sehr zu wenig jetzt
muss ich sagen mit diesem konkreten Fall
beschäftigt und mein Grundvertrauen in
deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden ist schon
noch so dass ich davon ausgehe wenn egal
Generalbundesanwalt da ein Grund zieht
um da so derweise gegen diese Person
vorzugehen dann wird es da auch eine
reale Gefahr gegeben haben aber was mich
sehr verwundert hat war dieses enorme
Medien aufgebaut die sofort diese Top
Berichterstattung in vielen Medien die
offenbar erkennen ließ dass diese
Journalisten da mindestens Tage vorher
schon Bescheid wussten und dahinter
steckt die Journalisten selbst sagen das
sind ihre investigativen Quellen die sie
da haben deswegen sind sie der top
informiert ich glaube das ist eine Art
von verdeckter Öffentlichkeitsarbeit ich
weiß nicht von wo aus aber man muss sich
nur gucken also da stecken auch
Interessen von Regierungsstellen
dahinter sich in den Medien als starker
Staat zu inszenieren
und das fand ich schon befremdlich ich
habe sie kurz schnaufen hören ich weiß
nicht ob sein Lachen war aber wollen sie
darauf reagieren findet da so etwas wie
auch in bei solchen Aktionen ist
dahinter auch wie so eine Art
PR-Strategie ein Zeichen dass man setzen
will wenn Sie das erlebt
also wir müssen unterscheiden
für den Bereich Sicherheitsbehörden und
die Politik wir haben ja in den
Ministerien eine politische Führung also
das sind ja gewellte Politiker das die
Diskussion auf dieser Ebene und die
Diskussion im Parlament beispielsweise
im Innenausschuss oder im
parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium für
die Nachrichtendienste dass die
politisch geführt wird ist gut und
richtig dass dort auch
Kommunikationsstrategien man will ja
seine Politik verkaufen und will das ja
beweisen dass man das gut macht dass
dort auch Kommunikationsstrategien
entwickelt werden das finde ich auch
völlig in Ordnung das ist unser System
das ist ja auch nichts neues das ist ja
nicht so als ob zum ersten Mal Politik
mit Presse zusammenarbeitet also deshalb
glaube ich das muss man unterscheiden
auf dieser Ebene und da kann man auch
dafür oder dagegen sein ist nicht mein
Thema mein Thema ist die
Sicherheitsbehörden und da glaube ich
nicht um ohne dass ich es weiß behaupte
ich
es gab niemand in den
Sicherheitsbehörden der das
durchgestochen hat wissen Sie wenn Sie
3000 Leute einsetzen alleine in
Deutschland und wir hatten ja noch zwei
ausländische Partner wo das auch
durchgeführt wurde wenn sie 150 Haus
durchsuchen machen das ist ein enormer
Aufwand das zu organisieren bei der
Stunde Null nämlich morgen zum 6 Uhr in
die Wohnung da reinzugehen zeitgleich
das alles auszuwerten das muss
vorbereitet werden das ist sie können
sich gar nicht vorstellen wie wie lange
man daran gearbeitet hat damit das
reibungslos funktioniert und es hat
reibungslos funktioniert und das in
einer solchen Phase Journalisten die
engen Kontakt zur Sicherheit würde X
oder zur lokalen Polizei y haben dass
die irgendwann mal was mitkriegen das
versteht sich für uns selbst also so
eine große Aktion lässt sich in einer
offenen Gesellschaft wie unsere nicht
total verheimlichen ich finde es sogar
ganz gut dass wir es geschafft haben
dass keiner dieser Journalisten der das
bekommen hat vorher darüber berichtet
hat sondern dass sie sich alle dann
daran gehalten haben und erst danach
berichtet haben also ich sehe da nicht
diesen pressegau oder diesen
kommunikationsgau das in der Politik das
bisschen anders noch differenziert wird
ist mir egal aber Herr Schindler wieso
was abläuft sieht man ganz gut in dieser
Doku die ist mal über die Bild-Zeitung
gab es gab noch Chef war da gibt es
diese Amazon Doku ja da gibt es eine
Szene wo Julian reichen
reaktionskonferenz geheimnisvoll fragt
wer denn zu ihm zu einem Hintergrund
Termin im Innenministerium vertraulich
mitkommt dann darf ein junger Kollege
mitgehen der freut sich man den Termin
sieht man ja Doku nicht aber hinterher
auf der Rückfahrt oder nach wird erklärt
um was es ging da wurde er erreiche
persönlich der Redakteur der
auflagenstärksten Zeitungen in
Deutschland persönlich vom Innenminister
weiß ich nicht aber imministerium
zumindest darüber informiert dass in den
nächsten Tagen eine groß angelegte Ratze
gegen gegen solche arabischen Clans
gegen die klaren Kriminalität glaube ich
war das irgendwo stattfindet
und dann hat ihre Redaktion genug Zeit
alles vorzubereiten die Live-Schaltung
und sowas und die radzer wird dann
wunderbar von Bild begleitet und das
Signal was der Staat damit senden will
mit Sicherheitsbehörden verkauft das ist
ich glaube es gehört zum Geschäft das
ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung dass der
Staat auch mal Härte zeigen will gegen
bestimmte Formen Signal sind will aber
ich denke kann ohne es zu wissen
vermutlich dass es in so einem in diesem
Fall sehr sehr ähnlich gelaufen ist und
das finde ich ist auch Aufgabe von
anderen Journalisten die nicht Teil
dieses Spiel sind ich gebe zu vielleicht
bin ich auch nur neidisch dass ich nicht
bescheid gesagt wurde
bitte auch
nicht nein das war Spaß ja natürlich es
gehört aber auch Aufgabe zu Journalisten
dann genau das zu hinterfragen weil man
dann schon immer die Gefahr hat dass da
auch was und deswegen war die Reaktion
so ob da vielleicht auch was aufgebaut
wird und zu einer Bedrohung zu einem
Staatsstreich äh der in Wirklichkeit
nicht zumindest nicht unmittelbar bevor
stand
sie das ganze erlebt Staat Streiche so
ein großes Wort und dann haben die
ersten Informationen man hat geplant den
Bundestag zu stürmen erstmal
unvorstellbar ja also ich habe mir jetzt
angewöhnt bei solchen Nachrichten dann
ähm darauf zu hoffen dass wir dann im
Nachhinein erfahren es gibt dann ja noch
Gerichte oder so die das überprüfen die
Vorwürfe und wie geht es immer so wenn
ich so viel Verhaftungen sehe dass die
Medien immer diejenigen so leid tun weil
sind ja teilweise noch nicht
ist noch nicht bewiesen also ich gehe
davon aus genauso wie sie die Behörden
haben das Material und das muss gemacht
werden wenn jemand verhaftet wird gegen
den ähm wenn man
versteht
ja also ich denke mal ich denke mal so
muss man keep cool also ich sehe es auch
nicht so die Medien waren immer schon
Heil also die haben schon in den 70er
Jahren sich an die gehören geklemmt und
haben alles möglich was sie konnten
schon seit
ein komischer es war wirklich wie
bestellt das war auch schon immer
bestellt also vom Spiegel was wo der
alles immer schon drin und was alles
wusste also ich glaube da sind wir dann
also so würde ich nicht daran gehen also
ich würde sagen das ist nun mal so aber
ich hoffe eben bei überbordenden
Berichterstattung immer dass die
Angeklagten oder die die Delinquenten
sage ich mal egal welcher Richtung sie
sind dass das dann
ja eigentlich aufgeklärt wird was jetzt
wirklich Sache ist also entweder ist es
berechtigt oder nicht immer das ist das
Einzige was wir vorher nicht wissen
können und auch nicht als Zuschauer dass
das was vielleicht die Behörde die hat
den Anfang Verdacht oder die hat schon
mehr als das und sonst würde sie nicht
zuschlagen ähm das durch die Medien
kommt eben dieses Ding rein dass wir
alle zu Hause sitzen und sagen das ist
ja alles richtig grauenvoll und dann das
tut mir grundsätzlich in unsere
Mediengesellschaft nicht jeder tut mir
leid aber wie viele Leute geraten heute
durch die Medien Historien in eine dann
vor Verurteilung und in dem Fall wird ja
was dran also sein sonst würden die
Behörden ja nicht zu schlagen also da
dann ist der dann haben sie recht er ist
Mitleid nicht angesagt aber ich finde
das in die Medien zu geraten heutzutage
mit Gesicht und Namen und so weiter
ist ein ein Problem mit dem wir uns
glaube ich alle irgendwie stellen müssen
es geht sehr leicht dass man dass man
durch eine Mediengeschichte und dann
denke ich mir die cool und wird man wird
irgendwann erfahren hoffentlich
hoffentlich
ob das alles so heiß gegessen wird oder
werden sollte wie man das gedacht hat
also muss man sagt nicht bleiben würde
ich sagen auf mal sachlich bleiben und
auch meine ganz kurze Pause machen wir
sind gleich zurück
bleiben Sie gerne bei uns bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst dass wir zu wenig
Stadt haben wir haben zu viel Staaten
wenn die alle wegfallen und wir uns
gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos
verkaufen das funktioniert nicht dann
ist mit wurscht aber das ist alles essen
als freiheitlicher Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den wir reden soll
[Musik]
das sind wir wieder zurück bei 8:15 Uhr
schön dass Sie bei uns sind und jetzt
starten wir erstmal mit einem Lob wir
wollen nämlich auch ein bisschen
positive Weibchen verbreiten und sie
haben mir gerade in der Werbepause
gesagt ein Lob Herr Schiller wollen sie
noch loswerden das wird auf jeden Fall
loswerden weil die Diskussion die wir
jetzt gerade geführt haben über
durchstechen nicht durchstechen
Kommunikation die lenkt natürlich mal
wieder davon ab worum es geht es geht
darum dass wir eine deutsche Polizei
haben dass wir Deutsche
Nachrichtendienst haben die ihre Aufgabe
erfüllen sie machen das Gut deutschland
gehört zu den sichersten Ländern im
internationalen Vergleich und das haben
wir nicht der Politik zu verdanken das
haben wir den vielen engagierten
MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeitern in den
Sicherheitsbehörden zu verdanken die Tag
und Nacht mit Leib und Leben sich dafür
einsetzen dass wir sicher sein können
und es ist zeigt auch die Razzia
beispielsweise gegen die klimakleber es
zeigt die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden
sind auf dem linken noch auf dem rechten
Auge blind sondern sie erfüllen ihre
Aufgabe und das glaube ich das muss man
in dieser Zeit dieser aufgeregten
Diskussionszeit auch einmal sagen denn
diese Leute haben unseren Respekt
verdient und ich glaube sie geben damit
auch ganz ganz vielen Menschen die uns
jetzt zuschauen ein ganz beruhigendes
Gefühl zu sagen Deutschland ist sicher
das ist so und das bleibt so sein dass
man in diesen Zeiten auch mal ganz gerne
hört wir kommen jetzt zu ihren Tier
ihren Tee das
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das ist nicht
unumstritten gerade jetzt in den letzten
Wochen ganz ganz große Diskussionen
Alice Schwarzer die Feministin hat sich
geäußert jan Böhmermann hat
zurückgeballert und sie sie haben ihre
ganze eigene Meinung dazu Rolle Ihre
Kamera ja also ich halte das neue
selbstbestimmungsgesetz für
verfassungswidrig und für
kinderfeindlich 14-Jährige sind nicht
umsonst noch nicht richtig strafmündig
sie sind noch nicht volljährig und jetzt
sollen sie plötzlich entscheiden kann in
einer Zeit wo sie eigentlich noch gar
nicht erwachsen sind
bei ihm ihren Namen zu ändern und auch
ihre Geschlechtsidentität im Pass zu
ändern also das ist ja noch nicht der
Punkt wo wir eine Geschlechtsanpassung
Operation und so weiter sind aber
plötzlich ermächtigen wir 14-Jährige
etwas ein Schritt zu machen wo sie
eigentlich nicht reif sind und wo ist
dann im ersten Gang kann das sogar ganz
nett und lustig klingen Jugendliche man
sieht hier überall jetzt äh das ist
nicht unbedingt so dass das erstmal so
negativ auffällt es könnte auch eine
Jugendmode im ersten Gang sein aber es
ist ja leider keine Mode sondern es ist
eine dahinter stehende gefährliche
Lobby und auch eine gefährliche Berater
Lobby ist explodieren es irgendwie Pilz
aus dem Boden kommen Kliniken die jetzt
nicht auf umoperationen auf transition
schon vorbereiten es wäre so schön wenn
es nur eine lustige provokante Jugend
wurde wäre und in den Kinderzimmern
jetzt sag ich mal ein Mädchen plötzlich
zu ihren Eltern gesagt ich bin junge und
ich heiße jetzt keine Ahnung Joe und
dass das bis dahin hat es ja ein
gewissen Reiz das kann man ja sogar
überall sehen oder ist man ja auch dann
tolerant aber wenn man dann hört dieses
selbstbestimmungsgesetz öffnet eben dann
nicht nur die Türen und Touren für
14-jährige dieses Pronomen sag mal zu
ändern sondern es ist dann ja auch die
Warnung Nomen ist Omen dann ist man
schon mal ein Junge statt ein Mädchen
und dann kommen ja die Angebote also da
ist diese Richtung schon sehr sehr
leicht und sehr gefährlich im Gange und
das allerschlimmste an dem ganzen
selbstverständlich
die die Öffnung für die das Eltern die
Kinder die die noch Kinder sind von vier
bis 13 dass sie eigentlich fast wie
eingeladen im Moment wirken
zu gucken ob ihre Kinder
immuntrant sind und da dann also mir so
fast noch lieber das 14-jährige selber
bestimmen können als das Eltern im noch
Vorschulalter anfangen darum zu gucken
und rum zu Doktor wie man das im
Saarländischen Rundfunk gesehen hat wo
eine Mutter mit einem neunjährigen
rumrannte und das wird der ihn als
Mädchen Anzug davon Hormonbehandlung
pubertätsblockern redete ihm einen
redete du willst doch gar kein Junge
werden ähm wir wollen das verhindern und
es gibt ja sogar ein Kinofilm über
Weihnachten wo es auch ein
siebenjährigen Jungen geht der
ein Mädchen werden will dass das das
finde ich noch dass ich noch beklemmen
da wenn es um die Kinder geht die sich
nicht wehren können und da kann auch mir
keine erzählen dass diese Kinder schon
selber bestimmen können oder sollen ähm
ob sie Mieter junge sind das das ist zu
früh und das ist euch der gefährlichste
Teil dieser früher Teil ähm der vor dem
14-jährigen gesehen und das wie gesagt
und das von der ganzen
Geschlechtsangleichung brauchen wir
nicht zu reden da steht eine Industrie
bereit die Jan Berater Funktionen macht
und da müssen auch die Berater was ich
mal anmerken denn die werden ja jetzt
gefordert
was haben die für Qualifikationen muss
gefragt werden haben die fertige Studien
haben die auch selber eine Familie
Partnerschaft haben die auch ein
erfülltes Sexleben und dann möchte ich
mein Statement Enden es wird in dieser
ganzen transdebatte extrem wenig über
das Thema Sex und Orgasmus geredet also
es wird irgendwie so getan weil ich kann
jetzt junge oder Mann sein oder ich kann
doch gar nicht operieren und ich habe
okay aber es wird irgendwann wird ja die
Frage doch gestellt was ist jetzt
eigentlich mit dem Thema Sex mit der
Thema der Orgasmusfähigkeit dieser junge
Menschen da pubertäts lockern und zwar
da geht es ja ins Eingemachte und das
ist auch der Grund weshalb das Thema
keine Mode ist und kein Spaß also ich
fahre jetzt einmal zusammen weil das war
eine ganz schöne lange speech ich
versuche auch einmal heraus keine Sorge
aber ich versuche einmal
heraus zu kristallisieren einmal für
mich herauszufiltern was sie da
befürchten also zum einen wird ja
erstmal die Tür aufgemacht für Menschen
selbstbestimmt und frei zu leben mit dem
Geschlecht mit dem Sie sich wohlfühlen
genau das könnte jetzt bis dahin gehen
Sie jetzt schon noch mal mit im Grunde
ja wenn ich da Jugendliche sehe das
könnte auch eine nette Jugend oder eine
etwas riskante aber irgendwie eine junge
Bewegung sein ja ist es aber nicht nee
ich glaube auch nicht dass wenn wir
jetzt jemanden der Transgender ist
vermutlich wahnsinnig viel
gesellschaftlichen Druck fühlt bestimmt
schon Diskriminierung ausgesetzt war
vielleicht auch psychische Probleme
dadurch hat der sich endlich traut sein
kann man auch zu machen ich glaube nicht
dass man dem sagt ist ja so eine
Entscheidung die Du damit also wir
müssen uns unterscheiden von denen
die wirklich Transsexuelle sind ich
finde die sind außen vor von dieser was
ich was passiert ist oder ich würde
sagen was ich in meinem eigenen Umkreis
sehe und höre ist das ich meine da ist
eine Schulklasse in unserem Nachbardorf
20 Kinder und sieben davon sind im
letzten Jahr plötzlich dran
ist sondern das ist eben dass man als
Kind auch ausprobiert Grundschule sagt
sie sieben Jahre alt schon ganz schön
Reise krass jetzt also alle haben andere
Namen alle haben sich gesagt sie sind
jetzt er oder sie hatte geändert und das
kann jetzt wird für die Eltern also erst
war das so weniger als sparsam aber das
wird für die Eltern jetzt schon ernst
denn können wir natürlich alles jetzt
nicht das ist eine anekdose jetzt aus
ihrer aber
noch mit reinholen in die Diskussion
sehen Sie diese sorgen die hier gerade
vorgetragen werden in dieser Debatte
teilen Sie das ja also ich sehe das auch
ich sehe dieses dieses Gesetz was jetzt
kommen soll wo ja im Grunde ist weil ich
es verstanden habe ist ja die Neuerung
dass man kein psychiatisches Gutachten
mehr braucht um das Geschlecht zu
wechseln und dass man es auch öfter hin
und her wechseln kann also ich kann es
künftig zum Standesamt gehen und dann
sagen ich bin eine Frau und dann werde
ich dann jeder Gräber ohne dass ich da
glaube ich das irgendwie begründen
müsste oder zu irgendeinem Arzt muss für
betroffen ist es natürlich eine
Erleichterung weil die sich vielleicht
von diesen Schritt auch sehen für die ja
aber das ist glaube ich also die
wirklich betroffen ist einfach eine sehr
eine sehr kleine Minderheit uns wird auf
der anderen Seite wirklich von von
Leuten keine Zahlen oder Studien die
wirklich betroffen
früher und dann kann man welche
Dunkelziffer das das wird ja schon aber
ich nehme jetzt mal an dass die meisten
Leute sich doch irgendwann mit ihrem
Körper anfreunden also 2020
das ist die Minderheit von der sie jetzt
beispielsweise sprechen sie dann aufs
Amt gehen und das muss also es gibt ja
auch es gibt ja auch Leute die sagen ich
bin eine Frau ich fühle mich als Frau
aber mein Körper lasse ich wie er ist
und ziemlich vielleicht noch anders an
oder lass mich im Pass jetzt unbedingt
das ist ja auch alles in Ordnung aber
sobald es in dem Bereich von Kindern
oder oder pubertierenden Kindern
hineingeht da muss man sehr sehr
vorsichtig sein weil jeder kennt es von
seiner eigenen Pubertät da weiß man ja
eine Zeit lang überhaupt noch nicht
Männlein Weiblein und wohin mit sich
selbst und seine Sexualität das ist ja
eine Findungsphase die jeder in
unterschiedliche Ausprägungen ja glaube
ich durchgemacht hat und da in so einer
Phase jetzt das zu einem medizinischen
Problem zu machen an dem auch Leute Geld
verdienen äh starke Medikamente zu geben
die die Geschlechtsentwicklung haben das
finde ich schon also es geht gar nicht
die Politik hier einmal reinholen
so ein bisschen abschichten sie hatten
uns vorher zu Gelassenheit geraten an
der einen oder anderen Stelle und
ich glaube es gibt zwei Bereiche das
eine ist glaube ich die Nachricht dass
Jugendliche wenn sie ihre Sexualität
entdecken und in der Pubertät sind
manchmal
Dinge tun die wir als Erwachsene
bisschen skurril finden ja und das nicht
ganz nachvollziehen können ist keine
neue Nachricht sondern das war schon
immer so und darum finde ich das Wort
von Modeerscheinung
da nicht passend was ist die
tatsächliche gesetzliche Änderung um
dies geht das hatten sie ja gerade
angesprochen es geht darum was muss ich
tun um den Verwaltungsakt dass das Amt
mir mit einem anderen Vornamen im Brief
schreiben darf
was muss ich durchlaufen damit das
geschieht und ich finde das sehr seltsam
dass ich wenn ich aufsamt gehe und den
sagt wie denn der Briefkopf um mich
anzuschreiben aussehen soll dafür ein
sehr entwürdigendes Verfahren
durchmachen muss bisher mit der
psychologischen Gutachten die sehr teuer
sind und dann eben dann auch die Rolle
spielt ist denn die Absicht zu einer
operativen Angleichung da oder nicht und
dann ist eigentlich doch die soll ich
sagen die die die
weichere Lösung dass man sagt man
eröffnet auch schon Jugendlichen mit 14
Jahren wo keine Operation stattfindet
dass sie dem neuen Vornamen schon mal
haben und sich dann darin einfinden
können und ich glaube da ist auch ja ein
bisschen Gelassenheit geboten und ich
also man kann man kann sehr also
meistens leiden Menschen darunter und
das ist trotzdem ein Bürokratie Aufwand
glaube ich eher zu dem Märchen deswegen
also es ist so dass das Transsexuellen
Gesetz extreme Härten hat die ich auch
ablehne also die würde ich ich finde es
ganz krass das muss ich da scheiden
lassen muss dass man zu Hause wenn man
da wirklich seinen Namen ändern will und
so weiter ist das ist das Transsexuelle
durchaus geändert werden finden es geht
jetzt um Kinder und Jugendlich Bereiche
die aus einer pubertären Provokation
jetzt auch von der Gesellschaft
angeheizt unter Umständen werden und ich
halte nicht alle Jugendliche für
Transsexuelle aber es ist es ist ein
gefährliches Spiel
damit mit der Sexualität zu spielen
also es ist ein gesellschaftliches
riesiges Thema es ist also es ist in den
USA wie gesagt die Kliniken ähm wie
Pilze aus dem Boden erst stoßen die ich
glaube es gibt Zahlen in was jetzt
Holland war dass er
1800 % mehr Jugendliche und Kinder sind
jetzt plötzlich dran also noch vor 20
vielleicht endlich trauen sich zu Hause
das ist eine These die auch Herr
Böhmermann
neulich vertreten an deiner Sendung und
das möchte ich mal anmerken dieses Thema
wird bei Böhmermann in einer Satire
Seite Sendung total durch den Kakao
gezogen und mit Nazi framing versehen
also jeder jede besorgte Mutter oder
Vater der sagt er möchte das nicht oder
oder auch besorgte Bürger die sagen wir
möchten nicht dass ein solcher Zugriff
auf Kinder geschieht werden da ja auch
schon auf eine unglaubliche Art
angegriffen und das darf auf dem Niveau
darf das nicht diskutieren
Erleichterung bekommen sollen wenn sie
ihr Geschlecht um die Kinder hören es
geht 100% um die Kinder jetzt möchte ich
um die auch wirklich zu Ihnen
rüberkommen Herz es geht um die Kinder
damit schließen wir nämlich den Kreis in
dieser Sendung hier sie haben das Gefühl
es wird schwierig Kinder aus sozial
schwachen Familien auf die
Aufstiegschancen überhaupt
Chancengleichheit Bildung zu kommen zu
lassen und das wollen sie ändern ihre
Zeit genau wir hatten Beginn der Sendung
schon drüber gesprochen dass Kinder in
den letzten Jahren einiges an Chancen
eingebüßt haben gerade wenn es um
Bildung und gesellschaftliche Teilhabe
geht und dann müssen wir dringend was
tun wenn wir über Kinderarmut sprechen
sprechen wir viel zu oft nur über den
materiellen Teil von Armut aber ein viel
größerer oder auch ein sehr großer Teil
in sehr wichtiger Teil davon hat eben
mit der Abwesenheit von Chancen zu
Teilhabe an unsere Gesellschaft von
Chancen auf Bildung und damit
Aufstiegschancen zu tun und auch mit
Räumen in denen dann
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung stattfinden
kann mir ist wichtig dass wir mehr
darüber sprechen was kann man tun Kinder
dabei zu unterstützen wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag ein
kinderschancenportal vereinbart des
Leistungen die es schon gibt die
brauchen kein neues Gesetz dafür gibt es
Bildungs- und teilhabepaket mit dem
Verwaltung und Vereine schon lange
Erfahrung haben aber es ist viel zu
kompliziert und kommt nicht bei den
Kindern an dringendsten brauchen den
Zugang müssen wir vereinfachen damit
Kinder einfach die Chancen haben diese
brauchen einen guten ins Leben zu
starten also machen wir es einmal
konkret was können wir für diese Kinder
tun den der Zugang zu allem möglichen so
erschwert ein erste Schritt ich mache es
mal plastisch ich war vor meiner Zeit im
Bundestag im Jobcenter und habe
tatsächlich diese Leistungen ausgereicht
das Bildungs teilhabepakets da werden
zum Beispiel Schulausflüge drüber
bezahlt und das läuft bisher so die
Eltern müssen beim Jobcentern Formular
abholen dass dem Kind mitgeben der
Lehrer muss das Ausfüllen das Kind muss
das ausgefüllte Formular wieder
unfallfrei nach Hause bringen die Eltern
bringen das dann wieder ins Amt und dann
irgendwann werden 20 Euro für den
Schulausflug überwiesen wer schon mal
mit achtjährigen Kindern umgegangen ist
weiß wie viele Fallstricke auf diesen
Weg da liegen und wie viele Flecken dann
auf diesen Formular sind und das kann
einfach nicht funktionieren unsere
Vorstellung ist dass es so einfach ist
wie bei einem Amazon Warenkorb dann wäre
Zugang hat zu diesem Leistungen die
online abzurufen vielleicht sogar wenn
die Schule im Spiel ist läuft das von
Behörde zubehörde direkt und dann klappt
das dann online in der Pandemie haben
und online das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
immer natürlich große Unterschiede der
fortschrittskoalition zur letzten das
wir von Digitalisierung was verstehen
und das dann auch aufs Gleis bekommen
und das ist jetzt glaube ich dringend
dass wir dass wir das tun und für arme
Kinder da was gutes einfach zustande
bekommen
Winter führt ohne Strom und ohne Gas ist
glaube ich nicht
nein im Januar auch hier einfach wieder
ja hoffentlich haben wir da ein Licht an
nein aber wirklich ich werde noch einmal
ernst drüber sprechen über die Kinder
was wird Ihnen geschildert wie nah sind
sie wirklich dran was sehen Sie bei
Kindern in Armut in Deutschland also ich
habe gesehen eben dass es ein
Unterschied macht wenn Kinder die
gleichen materiellen Mittel zur
Verfügung haben weil sie zum Beispiel es
gibt zwei Leistungen bekommen also
volkstümliche Hartz IV bald
Eltern wissen wie man Teilhabe an
Gesellschaft gestaltet dann weiß also
wenn ich will dass mein Kind Fußball
spielt und ich weiß ich muss dazu zum
Vereinsvorstand gehen und sagen mein
Mädchen möchte gerne bei Euch mitkicken
ich kann mir aber den beitragen ich
leisten und weiß die meisten Vereine
finden dann schon eine Lösung dass das
klappt
eröffnet seinen Kindern dann große
Chancen zu Teilhabe wer sich vielleicht
bei uns nicht so gut in der Gesellschaft
auskennt oder von der Bürokratie
überfordert ist der kann seinen Kindern
dann diesen Weg nicht eröffnen der ihm
viel helfen würde ich denke zum Beispiel
eine Mutter die aus der Ukraine
geflüchtet ist mit zwei Kindern die sehr
viele Sorgen hat eine Sprachbarriere hat
aber weiß wenn man Kind am Mittwochabend
eine Runde Fußball spielen könnte das
würde ihm sehr gut Ablenkung dann müssen
wir das einfach
machen
Zettel haben schauen wir genau weiter
drauf
das auch gelingt dass man allen Kindern
die gleichen Chancen geben kann großer
Wunsch hier auch vielen herzlichen Dank
für eine spannende Sendung an meine
Gäste vielen herzlichen Dank fürs
zusehen wir sehen uns wieder wenn Sie
mögen wir morgen machen sie es gut bis
dann
[Musik]